i also am really happy to be here very
grateful for the chain
favorite things which is preserving land
so my topic is art and land conservation
and we're going to start with a quote
that is at the entrance to the
Smithsonian's Museum of American Art so
it acts as the context and focus for all
of the art on the ground floor and the
second floor all of which is landscape
painting and here's the quote it's
pretty amazing because what we find is
well it's partly covered what we find is
there was pretty much a good sense of
confidence that we were a garden and to
me a garden obviously in 1901 we'd
already solid a lot of it and this is
part of what led John Muir whose quote
this is to cooperate and teach Teddy
Roosevelt quite a bit about what needed
to be preserved and set aside in
different kinds of gardens but what we
have found in the last 111 years since
this quote is that our definition of
what our land is is much more complex
involves a lot of other things than just
being considered a garden or something
even that is just about natural
resources that we could exploit and use
so beyond from this early period having
forests which are perceived as timber
and trees and lumber or fields which
were farms and food we also now have a
host of things as all of you know the
concern about climate change how
resilient will we be what happens with
biodiversity and so on artists and land
conservation groups are responding to
that new complexity and what we're
finding is that a lot of natural
preservation groups started out saying
well we've got to preserve for
biodiversity the trend now is to say we
know we just have to do preservation
we're not exactly sure that we're always
going to be hitting the top most
important aspect but if people say they
want to preserve it we probably should
preserve it it means they'll come up
with some money to do it and likewise
artists are saying I'm not exactly sure
what it is that is most worrisome to me
or most opportunistic to me and what I
do with this concept I have have land in
the complexity of our fragile world but
I'd like to begin to approach it and
work with it sometimes in the landscape
as well so I'm going to look at some of
the net results of this recently we now
have 747 million or so acres preserved
in this country that's twenty percent of
the landmass those have been for multi
purposes sometimes it's about protecting
water food working landscapes of other
sorts playgrounds dog parks are the most
rapidly growing type of park that's
risen by thirty four percent in the last
couple of years people like their
off-leash dog parks because they're
having fewer children or their empty
nesters artists also have come at this
from multiple perspectives as we've seen
and I'd like to focus on two in the new
york region so that you could actually
go visit them if you wanted to or see
something about their work I've got
these two brochures out on the hallway
next to where James's art is got little
sign up sheets if you would like to buy
some of the art that's out there and
these will tell you something they're
sort of guides to what's going on and
some of the projects i'll talk about so
pick those up the two artists are
deborah friedman a painter born in 1947
and george trakis an environmental
artist born in 1944 they both work in
this region you don't have to travel to
Marfa Texas or to the spiral jetty to
see something about this work so we've
got two ladies here the one on the right
is Deborah Freedman this is actually
taken just a couple of weeks ago out at
the new site of the FDR four freedoms
memorial that's designed by Louis Kahn
it's only being realized now as you know
Khan died in the 70s but this is a major
undertaking they have raised most of the
money all of the masonry is now in place
it is a phenomenally beautiful site and
i would urge you to go actually doesn't
have anything to do with what i'm
talking about but I happen to be there
in the pictures of Deborah so what she
has done is in her work is taken the
more traditional view
with the media that's painting and
printmaking she does monotypes and she
does a oil painting mostly but these are
of a size and scale that fit on a wall
and can go in a museum and are really a
sort of an extension of the earlier 19th
century concern with the sublime in the
American landscape Deborah basically
started out with a good deal of up close
in forest paintings waterfalls trees
there was almost no horizon line but 911
actually deeply affected her and she
began to paint what she called disturbed
landscapes and she took more seriously
what it meant to have preserved land
near where she lived out in the
countryside this is the Shokan reservoir
which is part of the system that
preserves water for New York City's
drinking so she began to get herself to
these sites spend a lot of time on them
and paint them over and over this
current series and I'm just going to
show you the two are from a series she
calls goodnight Irene and this is based
on the hurricane irene which of course
was ironically named since it wasn't in
any way ironic and it further disturbed
her because she felt now we had not we'd
gone beyond the concerns that she had
about how to keep the water safe and
clean access to those reservoirs open
because of concern about terrorists and
the civil oversight that clamp down on
access to the reservoirs after 911 but
now we also were facing in great good
elven certainty about the impact of
nature and what would happen when
hurricanes ripped through and destroyed
towns her interest was really to be able
to say in this series I'm concerned
about my small towns I'm not sure that
we can really say goodnight Irene you
know as and put you to bed Irene and get
rid of you but her worried that the
devastation might return is still
causing a good deal of artistic
interpretation that's abstract and that
has a heightened sense of worry and
concern I think there's a good deal of
that certainly in Alexis's work but in
others where people are
saying are you are you awake are you
paying attention is this going to make
you move and do something as obviously
is not in any way a road map but I'm
going to turn now to Jorge trakis who's
actually taken this art as many artists
have outside of the museum so he doesn't
work in drawings or paintings he jumps
outside and he gets to work on the
landscape it's what I like to think of
as analogous to slow food it's slow art
he goes out into the landscape builds a
little boat putters around in the water
really gets to know the place and then
comes up with some ideas about what he
could do on the land so I'm going to go
through three of them chronologically
this is beacon landing this is very
accessible it's in New York right near
the DIA beacon and dia beacon was
instrumental in getting this place
started because scenic Hudson one of the
great land Trust's in the Hudson Valley
had purchased some land and was going to
preserve it and the DIA beacon people
said rather quietly to some of us
involved in art well we're not sure that
scenic Hudson has ever really considered
art when it's had a park or if they have
we've never seen evidence of it so we
were hoping that since this is really
relational to our new museum that you
would help us find an artist who can
handle the development of the site the
site itself is 22 acres it was an
abandoned railway shunting yard it was
all landfill and as with much of where
George works it's been abandoned misused
abused it's often quite polluted and he
came into the site again did his stuff
at the boat began to meet people in the
area and got to work with permitting and
as he says his process is actually
really it loves to engage with people
including the Army Corps of Engineers
they don't frighten him at all he was
told that it would take him years to get
the permits but in fact it took him
about four months so he works very
closely he gets out there that this is
that's his car so he drives up and down
sometimes he's on the train it's a
little Hut so he has a safe place to be
when the weather is stormy on the huts
and you're seeing the backside of a sign
that you saw on the front side on the
other one just a little bit of it there
on the side and it basically says there
are dangerous cables under this water no
one may anchor here so you're not
allowed to move that sign it has to stay
so he integrates it into what he does
that's the inside of the hut where he
spends a good deal of time different
people he's found in there sleeping when
he shows up and here we already have the
the integration of what he does so he
takes the environment as he finds it
works with it in order to anchor it into
place and give it some reminiscent
feeling of the original shoreline he
accounts for now we're seeing the laying
of the planking on top of all that
infrastructure of steel but he gives the
water a space to move for high tide and
low tide you can get to this water in a
wheelchair not that you have to be in a
wheelchair but it is absolutely a
counterintuitive to what usually happens
in a park by seeing a cousin or anyone
else which along the Hudson has to
conform to permitting and is usually
built with a 13 foot high bulkhead wall
in order to be ready for a hundred year
storm event and to keep people safe and
like Mark was saying with the registrar
at the London Museum people are
incredibly afraid of the water they
consider it very dangerous so this was a
really maverick thing for him to do and
he felt quite an accomplishment to be
able to get access and as soon as the
place is built it fills up with people
and come out in fact it's beginning to
surprise and sort of annoy the
caretakers because they're not quite
sure these are school classes this group
is here talking to the crabbers who are
showing them how they're crabbing works
there are more people there than anyone
thought would be there there's a little
boy if he were to turn to the right he
would see this George makes it very
possible to get to the water to sit down
to stroll to lie
and they really are getting many more
people than they ever thought they would
have another site that he's worked in is
in New York City the land here is
obviously much more valuable but in fact
this is in an area where no one wanted
this land it's on Newtown Creek and
that's what it's known as the Newtown
Creek water treatment facility the
Newtown Creek Park itself is about two
acres of built space but it sits around
like an outer edge that people can get
to around a water treatment plant that
handles 600 million gallons of water a
day it's one of New York City's 14 water
treatment plants you probably know the
one that you pass when you're on the
west side highway that they build off of
Harlem and that involved a lot of
community attention and activity this
one also involved some community
activities is very blighted part of
northern Brooklyn and the community per
se said during the original meetings
that George went to what do you mean
you're going to make a park and we're
not going to be part of it how are we
going to get to it there's no access
what do you mean it's only for the
people who work in the water treatment
plant no no no we have to have access so
George came up with a way to get into it
this is his ideal of how it will be used
over time again you see the steps going
down to the water so you can get in and
out of your vessel but the way you get
to it is by going to a dead end parking
your car there about 20 parking spots
because there's no mass transit there
and you go in through a series of gates
that are very reminiscent of highly
stylized waves and there are light
features that are about nautical
elements you go up and over the plant
itself it's about seven hundred and
forty feet of walking this you get to
one end you turn around and you see the
Empire State Building so you're really
located in New York City you should know
where you are when you see this you turn
back heading north and you come down
toward the water and again you've got
these wonderful spaces on both sides of
the steps as our little handrails he was
very responsive to people in the
community they said they they knew he
loved water so what was he going to
other than getting them access to the
water these handrails are h2o molecules
you see them and again he's got these
long steps which remind me he says they
don't have anything to do with it but
they remind me of the ghats in India
where you go to the sacred River in
order to really commune with the water
and where the water will take away all
of your sins so he says no it's not
really about that it's just to get to
the water and hear the hear the lapping
and be part of it this particular water
is actually kind of dangerous there are
signs all over that he could not have
them take out that say pregnant women
watch out children watch out nobody
should touch it nobody should eat
anything from it so there's a whole lot
of scolding going on around here you
turned the corner and the he's got these
big boulders that they found on the site
and you walk back in and their native
plants their places to sit and there's a
there's six different spots where you
could have a dock and you can tie up on
these bollards and again find a place to
sit now the last one is in Queens and
it's in socrates park which maybe some
of you know about that was started by
Isamu Noguchi and marc de su borough in
the 60s de su borough is a maybe a
little more famous now because one of
his statues was in Zuccotti Park so when
the Occupy Wall Street people were there
the big red statute kind of became part
of what people were seeing but in the
background here you'll you will see not
only a construction crane but to the
right of the crane some of marks work
this is what the park looks like today
it's got a lovely spring going on here
this is just about a week ago I was out
there and you can see that there's guys
sitting on the far side of the fence
because he jumped the fence he doesn't
want to sit back and this is a very
human tendency to want to get right to
the water he's actually sitting up sort
of hi this is what the shoreline looks
like around there you can see that sort
of the green scum that's the rise and
fall of the tidal action there this is
toward roosevelt island so you're
looking straight west maybe you'll see
the city court building in the
background with a diagonal roof this is
a very very typical of New York City's
waterfront it's you know 650 or so miles
of riprap that keeps you back if it's
not looking so great it looks like this
falling apart and if it's looking pretty
good it's actually stabilized riprap
with a railing and you may be allowed to
go to it and look out over but again
don't go too near so a big part of what
George trakis is offering is the ability
to get into the water but he's also
offering the opportunity and this is
done by the noguchi museum and the
curators there to have the artist in a
environmental setting that involves the
entire community and these are visioning
sessions that for different artists are
involved in and then George chose this
projects there's George at the site yes
it's very typical there's a lot of
cyclone fencing keeping people away he's
got his generator so that he can go down
below and put the stuff in he's almost
always on site if you happen to go
before he opens this on May thirteenth
you'll probably see him there you get
down to the water level and you see that
he's those pins are now holding some of
this these piers there nine columns and
he's calling it soon Yin as a pun on
union at this this is very typical so he
will again you can see the historic
remnants of seaworthy craft and peers
that are there that's a big boat house
in the back that isn't used for boats
anymore and back to this final shot
simply because I think what this does is
show that degraded landscapes can be
preserved they can have an artistic
element to them that really allows
people to come in they didn't even know
that they wanted to be there it's
surprising everybody when he asked high
school students that came have you ever
been down to this water they said no of
course not you know we're inside
watching TV and doing our video games so
it is actually doing a lot of
what we know needs to be done and it's
happening almost despite ourselves thank
you